David, I hear often that the country is more
divided than ever, but it's divided for a
good reason.
One side is insane.
Is it really that bad for the country to be
divided?
I think it's important to, to answer this
question, to understand that partisanship
and division are two different things, and
I'm not saying the country isn't divided,
but divided might point more towards the types
of circumstances that would lead to a civil
war.
Right?
We're half the country wants to separate the
South wants to succeed in order to maintain
state's rights, to have slavery be illegal,
for example.
We don't have that level of division right
now.
There are some secessionists but not that
many.
A lot of us who say, Hey, if the red States
want to bail, go ahead.
We are the financially viable blue States.
We're sort of joking.
I mean it would be extraordinarily damaging
to the country if the country were to separate
into financially.
Even if mathematically in the long run the
blue States would be fine and the red States
wouldn't, um, it would be such a jolt to the
system that it would be very bad for the economy.
For, for a while the partisanship we are seeing
is partially because we are sort of coming
to a potentially big change in the path of
America and I don't want to excuse the partisanship
as merely sensible because of this precipice
we might be approaching.
Part of the reason we have this partisanship
is because of partisan media, including the
existence of Fox news and other right wing
media, a carrying water in a way that doesn't
relate to the facts on the ground at all.
Social media echo chambers.
Like there are some really toxic reasons why
we have such partisanship that even though
the country has moved to the left, a lot of
money is still raised by the right by kind
of hunkering down these extremist reactionary
positions on abortion and immigrants and so
on and so forth.
So there's a lot of really horrible reasons
why we have partisanship, but also our system
rewards partisanship.
If you run centrists campaigns, it becomes
harder to raise money for reelection because
you're not appealing to the people who are
most um, radical.
And I use that term non-judgmentally when
it comes to issues.
Radical positions justify and encourage more
donations.
And that's part of the system that we have.
But to some degree, the election of Donald
Trump was insane.
And now there is a question, are, are we reelecting
Trump and saying Trump was not an anomaly
or an anomaly, depending on which pronunciation
you like, we are, we've had four years of
Trump and we're going to four more.
That would be a huge thing for the country
to do.
On the other hand, we have the possibility
of electing the most progressive presidents
in the history of the United States.
Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren, uh, even
some of the other candidates would be more
progressive than anyone else who has been
president so far.
So I believe that the hyper partisanship in
part is also because of this precipice of
possible significant change that we're going
to have the media fomented the media profits
from it, no question about it.
And we are living in two different realities.
Media foments that in part the internet is
a huge part of it.
You have everything from militant conspiracy
theorists, more and more white supremacy far
right, hyper nationalist types.
There is increasingly a lack of middle ground
represented in media.
Social media reinforces more and more extreme
versions of whatever it is that you believe
or support and it's extraordinarily powerful.
Getting through to people and saying, let's
be sensible becomes difficult and often not
rewarded.
When, when you look at polls about what TV
shows, what podcasts, what websites the left
and the right are looking at, they are very
different and they are increasingly ones that
merely reinforce and continue to radicalize
that preexisting worldview.
So serious division has many negative effects.
Both sides can be more easily controlled by
a minority of their side, uh, by picking the
issues that will most catalyze and rational
and a reaction.
Air create views and that can be done in perpetuity
to keep increasing the division or partisanship.
Uh, the deepening political divide can also
lead to violence.
We've talked about how many of us believe
if Donald Trump were to be, uh, um, removed
from office by losing in 2020, but claim that
it was unfair that it was rigged in some way.
I fear that there would be violence and uh,
hyper partisanship and division can also cause
that, but I don't believe the country is so
much divided as it is hyper-partisan which
comes with its own set of issues.
What do you think is the country divided?
Hyper-partisan a little bit of both.
One or the other.
I want to hear from you